how was your day what made him a great
dad because he had to have been really
busy
right um you know what he he was very
present
and he figured out uh my parents
together figured out
given their life situation how to be
present and it looks different for every
single family you know like everyone has
a lot of plates that they're spinning
and um
and it's different for every individual
and so um
what that looked like in terms of my
childhood was we were just traveling
you know my mom would like figure it out
so that all four kids we could go
wherever my dad was going and we would
enroll in local schools and
or get homeschooled and wow it's almost
like touring musicians
it's almost like how because a lot of
musicians bring their kids on the road
and families on the road
yes that's exactly exactly it and it was
awesome because i loved it
and my parents figured out pretty early
that they could
really control me by threatening that i
wouldn't be allowed to go to set if i
didn't behave
i'm not above bribery or threatening
myself yeah
no i think that's cool yeah yeah
well yeah surprise for you oh
father's day surprise for you um a
mother's day
yes a video with sent us just for you
here here we go
we're gonna play it hey kelly well let's
see an embarrassing story about
bryce she was a great kid uh and she
loved visiting the set and she was very
very helpful
in fact by the time she was 11 or 12 she
was actually
pitching in as like a production
assistant
in in fact she was she was so efficient
that
she was finally given the responsibility
of having
a walkie-talkie you know so that the
production assistants could talk to one
another and give direction and
and and guidance and and i mean that was
that was a real
honor and a show of uh you know of
appreciation
for how mature she was it was great the
first day she was terrific she was
on it the second day was good too except
suddenly over the walkie-talkie
we heard bryce ordering the
extras holding area to be moved from one
side of a building over to the other
now now granted she was trying to get it
out of the sun and into the
shade and her thinking was pretty good
but it's not quite cool
to have the 12 year old taking over the
production so
she lost her walkie-talkie that day but
i knew that one day she'd want to be
behind the scenes calling the shots
and she does it really well subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going